[Music]
all right people
i'm hitting tweet and that means we're
live this is the reuben report direct
message
for september 29th 2020
and i got to tell you people i'm feeling
good about the world because
uh the first presidential debate
is tonight if it's gonna actually happen
i'm still 50 50 on that
uh because lord only knows what'll
happen over the next couple hours
uh but yes assuming nothing crazy
happens
there is going to be a debate tonight
obviously i'm going to spend most of the
time today
with some predictions some thoughts
we'll talk about trump's
taxes we'll talk about uh the fact that
in the last hour or so
the biden people asked for two breaks
they wanted two
breaks at half hour points in the debate
and uh
apparently a few days ago he agreed to
be checked for an earpiece now they're
going back on that i mean just more
theater like there's no business like
show business folks it's just
it's going to be bananas it's going to
be wild you can already see the the
the ground being laid for if you like
biden
why you know he's going to win and if
you like trump why he's going to win and
the rest of it so we're going to spend
most of our time
talking about that and i did want to do
one
other quick story because one of the
things that i told you when we started
this thing
was that i want to do the things that
are sort of culturally
relevant and not just keep you in the
weeds on all of the political
stuff of the day so i saw this clip you
know i try not to
tweet on the weekends as you guys know
and actually a whole bunch of you have
started joining me
in that adventure which is pretty great
and i think it really helps with sanity
and clarity and
uh and just distancing yourself from the
the endless
reaction to everything so it's it's been
great that so many of you do that so i
try not to tweet on the weekends
and actually i didn't tweet yesterday
either because it was yom kippur which
is the holiest day in the
in the jewish year that is when you
atone
for your sins obviously i'm a man with
no sin but you know i was there anyway
had i had a bagel
and uh and here we are but a video did
come across to me
this morning that was posted i guess on
twitter over the weekend
and it was on originally on tick-tock
which is a little unclear to me whether
tick-tock is still a thing or is it
legal or is it illegal or trump said he
was getting rid of it then there's a
lawsuit to keep it
and it's a whole big mess but whatever
you think about tick-tock and the
chinese government spying on our
children through apps that go viral and
that whole thing
there was a really interesting video
it's it's about 50 seconds we're going
to show it to you in just a sec
uh of a young person a young guy
i think it's a guy it sounds like a guy
a young guy going up to two cops in a
new york city subway station
and then taping the interaction and
presumably
presumably posting it because they think
they came off looking good and that the
cops came off looking bad and i want to
show you this
and then we'll we'll talk about it after
but i wanted to show you this because i
think people don't
realize really have any um
insight into what police officers not
just in new york city although i think
it's a particular brand of this in new
york city
but all over the country are dealing
with on a day-to-day basis and sort of
these
self-righteous people that just get in
their face
all day long and try to push them over
the edge so let's throw to the clip
if i don't wear a mask what does the
final card best
meter to you guys
it states that as long as you can
maintain six feet distance you don't
have to wear them
if you want to step within six feet of
me i'll gladly put on the mess
so would you like to do that i mean i
feel like you guys are living less than
60 to because you're the one that
approached us so would you like to keep
the distance
okay now we're six feet away and i don't
know i mean i mean
you've got i mean you should probably
run an asparagus you're the person that
calls someone you know what i mean
someone sound like water bottles
thank you for your service sir thank you
for protecting us during a pandemic
all right so that line that one of the
officers says you're the male
version of karen is is just so perfect
and again i'm showing you this
not in radia not to do any of that
but just to understand what the average
police officer is dealing with on a
daily basis these guys are sitting there
minding their own business they both
come off as really freaking decent
human beings right they are apparently
of different races
they're new york city police officers
they most likely went
into that job to protect the public
they're not hunting anybody down they're
not acting in a racist fashion or
bothering anybody
but this person thinks because he has
this weapon
in his face that he can get in their
face demand this thing about the masks
and the six feet
then the smug uh way at the end you know
thank you for your service
and it's like i want to get your name so
i can get the mob to go after you
mr police officer and and that's why i
wanted to bring up the video it's not
really because of the interaction it's
that thing that really
is a is a true sickness in our society
like
this kid basically he saw them probably
from a distance and then thought this is
my moment
to get retweets or read tick-tocks what
do they call it on tick-tock i don't
know
um or or whatever it is like just get
some notoriety to
show you that the cops are bad and
meanwhile they come off looking like
absolute all-stars patron saints good
people and and then he still posts it
thinking and that that's the other part
of why this thing is sort of a mental
condition
he posts it thinking oh i came off
looking good look how i made these cops
look because they weren't social
distancing
it looks like they're partners and
actually if they've done their due
diligence which no doubt they have
they've
probably been tested and they're making
decisions on their own you know cops are
free citizens as well
at least for now so anyway it was worth
just showing because
uh if you see a cop uh maybe just give
them a nod
or a hand i don't know if you can you're
allowed to handshake people can you
shake hands anymore is that a thing
or just uh or just say something nice i
i've been trying to do it uh here and
again when i
when i see a cop on the street or on the
corner when i'm walking my dog or
whatever it might be
uh because by and large these are these
are good people who go into service to
to keep the rest of us safe and you know
it's like
this kid like so many of these
protesters it's the same thing
it's like man you know if if the mob
ever went after you or if someone broke
into your house or broke into your car
or anything else ever happened the first
thing you do is call the cops there's a
really hilarious
viral video from a few months ago where
a bunch of uh black lives matter antifa
protesters are
you know screaming the cops are racist
blah blah blah blah all the usual
anti-cop stuff
and then some guy gets out of his car
and he he's got some sort of weapon it
almost looks like wolverine's claw i'm
sure a bunch of you saw this
and he runs at them and then and then
one of the girls is screaming somebody
call the cops
and it's like irony you have been killed
in 2020. okay let's let's move on
because i want to spend the rest of the
time i've got about 20 minutes here i
want to spend the rest of the time
uh doing some pre-debate analysis
and and making some predictions so first
off
it seems like everything has led us here
right like it's finally going to get to
a place where these two
elderly gentlemen are able to talk
directly to each other apparently
they're going to be
doing more than the uh six feet social
distinct
social distancing it'll be even wider
than that and i guess there are going to
be some
people in the crowd but it'll be pretty
sparse um
so let's just go through the stuff that
that sort of everyone knows at the
moment
first off on the uh we'll start on the
biden side
so on the biden side the the major
advantage
that joe biden has that that the media
doesn't really want to talk about
obviously
is that there are basically no to to
maybe
very low expectations for biden if biden
can basically
stand up there for the 90 minutes the
hour and a half
and not completely lose his train of
thought not
completely butcher numbers and say the
200 million are dead because of covet
instead of 200
000 or just the rest of the crazy stuff
that he's been saying there was another
video i saw
this weekend where apparently like it
appeared that he was basically
thinking that trump's name was john like
just like just this endless cascade of
stuff
that i keep telling you guys the scandal
is obviously not that something's wrong
with him
everybody knows there's something wrong
with him and again i just don't think
they expected him to break down this
quickly i think the party leaders and
whoever's in charge of the dnc they
wanted him to get
through the election hopefully get voted
in obviously and then you do what you
got to do and then congratulations we
got
president kamala who that is whether
that's the dnc or the obamas or the
clintons or
something else or without going too far
down a conspiracy rabbit hole
like i don't know who that is but i
don't think anyone thought he was gonna
break down
this quickly um so in a certain way he
has a huge advantage here right because
the expectations are so low
like he just has to basically go up
there and not screw up he has to be
calm be able to string some sentences
together
and and then it will basically look like
a win for him
the expectations for trump obviously are
much higher because trump
basically is a good debater uh and he's
good on television whether
whether you like trump hate trump
whatever it is i think most people would
say
um even even most of the hillary people
last time thought that
that i think thought that he won two of
the three
debates obviously that's that's a bit
subjective but the point is the guy
knows how to work television so forget
wins debates loses debates the guy knows
how to talk to a camera
he knows how to get a crowd going he
knows how to do it and
let's not forget he has spent the last
month traveling
being with crowds feeling the
temperature
of the country biden i did a story on it
last week
i think it was up to as of yesterday it
was up to 11
times in september he called a lid on
his campaign by around 10 a.m
this phrase calling a lid on a campaign
i had never heard before i'm guessing
you had never heard before
this is when they basically tell the
press yeah we're done doing anything
public for the rest of the day
as if there aren't enough things that he
could be and probably should be
commenting on
uh now it's possible people are saying
he's been preparing for the debates i
mean
i i don't know if that's true that you
know i i suppose all of this will
come to light one day because again as
i've been saying the scandal is the
non-scandal
so it's like when it breaks that they've
been hiding this from the public that
that the dnc
has put up a candidate with dementia and
everyone knows it or what or whatever is
going on with him and again i don't mean
to be glib about it
i don't think i'm being glib i don't
think i'm being sarcastic or even trying
to be funny about it
it just it just is what it is um and you
have to comment on it if you see it you
know
one of the versions of fake news that i
talk about in my book
is that a type of fake news isn't just
when they give you a fake story or when
this the headline doesn't really match
the news itself a type of fake news is
when they won't touch a story because it
doesn't fit the narrative
so the mainstream media doesn't want to
touch the fact that something's wrong
with bite and then i tweet it out and
i'll do it again today by the way i'll
do it i'll do it when we finish this
i tweet out every few weeks you know
will somebody
you know a blue check verified person on
twitter with a decent following some
public person not not just a genderless
anime
avatar of a fox will someone with a
decent following who is who's supporting
biden will you get out there and
go on the record and say that you don't
think something's wrong with him that
you don't think
he has either the early stages of
dementia or some other cognitive problem
and i've tweeted this out a bunch of
times and nobody will do it
and and that's why last week when i was
talking about sort of the failure of the
liberals
it's like where are the good the good
remaining liberals now i get it
the progressives you know they called in
order 66
they executed mostly you've you've had
to run and hide in the hills this is
sort of the barry weiss it's the
the idw crew it's like everyone's sort
of gone now
because the problem is i think many of
them
and many of the liberals and you're
probably you probably you might be one
of these people or you might have these
people in your family
if you went so deep on the trump
derangement stuff
well then even if you think biden
has dementia or if you think biden is
just
the the empty shell that's going to lead
in the socialist
it's like you can't turn around and say
oh the hitler guy
he's actually better so everyone is sort
of stuck in there
in their weird sort of self-imposed
prisons at the moment um
so look the expectations for biden are
low the expectations are trump from
uh for trump are high so that that
asymmetry
creates a problem now let's also
remember that you know
this idea of winners and losers it's
like this is this is very much a sort of
media construct like someone will
win you know like someone will do a
better job than the other it's very rare
that a debate ends and you're like boy
they both really made a whole bunch of
good points and i have to think further
about what i'm going to do
but the thing is that it's a media
construct because most
people at the moment you pretty much
know who you're going to vote for
you may not be being public about it now
that that's an interesting thing that
that
i've been thinking a lot about and that
again goes to what i was just talking
about the liberals i think there's a lot
of the same liberals who realize what's
coming behind biden with the democrats
and they're going to secretly vote for
trump
but it's hard to imagine and i'd love to
uh
to hear your thoughts on this so if you
want to comment in the youtube comment
section although it's very hard
to go in there and read anything so the
best way if you want me to read your
thoughts on this join us at
reubenreport.com and you can comment and
i jump in there and i talk to people and
we've got live chat
that we'll do we'll be doing tonight
during the debate but i'd love to hear
people's thoughts on this like
the the people that at this point are
undecided it's hard to sort of imagine
what that mental state is right so
if you're a traditional conservative
you're you're voting for trump or or
you're like a never trumper and then
you're going to vote for biden
who stands for all the things that
you're supposed to be against i don't
really understand it but like i can get
that that's a thought and if you're a
traditional democrat well
if you're into the progressive side of
stuff then you're obviously going to
vote for biden and
and most likely you've gone so deep in
the anti-trump stuff that you can't
you can't negotiate it as i just said so
you go there
but i think that the interesting group
of
people right now is the disaffected
lefties the walk away people but not the
ones who fully walked away and said okay
i'm moving this way
but it's all the other people who are
sort of like
something ain't right with biden we know
what's coming next
with the democrats like the socialists
are here that's the future of the party
and it's like are you going to publicly
support trump or not
again just whether you like the guy
whether you think he's great or
or whatever it is like that so the idea
that basically
there's this undecided group at the
moment it's hard to picture
who that is um because the sides really
are so different and you know
every every election of course they
always say this is the most important
election and this is the most important
election of a generation this is the one
not the one last time we said it last
time we were kidding
this is the one the thing is this is the
one
like this is it this is it way more than
last time because last time
there were like the trump last time was
just this like crazy
x factor that was being completely
dismissed by the media and
basically the idea was and and this is
what pretty much everyone was saying
hours into voting having started you
know hillary's got a 96
chance and then we watched all the
mainstream media people's head explode
the idea now that was obviously an
important election because had
had hillary won well let's let's try to
do it this way had hillary won i think
what would have happened is
all the sort of bad forces that we're
seeing right now the identity politics
stuff
and and the critical race stuff and the
movement of the socialists and all that
it would have been empowered in a
certain way because the democrat would
have won
but in another way it might have been
tempered down because
because it wouldn't have had trump to
view as the ultimate evil it would have
viewed hillary as evil but trump is the
ultimate evil he's even got a red hat
that seems scary
so so it's hard to say what what the
world would look like right now
because i think in in many respects and
this is what i've been trying to
to explain to my friends that are on the
fence especially the ones that are that
are lefties or ex-lefties
is that if hillary had won the
forces that we've all been fighting
against against identity politics the
forces against
big government and all of these things
they really the screws
of the machine would have been tightened
right because hillary would have just
been a continuation
of those things i'm not saying she would
have been the worst president and again
full cards on the table i didn't know
what i was going to do when i walked
into that voting booth and i'm in
california where we knew it was going to
be a landslide
for a democrat and i ended up voting for
gary johnson third party i will not do
that this time
i don't think i have the luxury of doing
it and i also think that the the
polls are going to be so out of whack
that i think everyone's vote counts in a
in a weirder uh more meaningful way than
than usual because i just don't think
the polls make
any sense right now i i just don't i
just think there's
there is something going on that
mainstream cannot get
mainstream just has even
even if even if biden wins by three
points let's say the average poll says
he's up by three points right now
i don't think that will be indicative of
the fact that the polls are saying that
right now i think everything is just so
out of whack i think so many people are
not saying what they think
that nobody anyone telling you they know
what's going to happen right now they're
just
they're just lying to you you can make
your best guess
you can you can try from you know
gleaning some information from the
people in your family and your and your
circles
and then sort of what's going on
nationally but like just
just nobody knows but in any event i
think if if hillary had won
the screws would have been tightened the
machine would have been sort of more
calcified
trump came and blew apart the machine
and now everyone's kind of all over the
place
and the question really is do you think
that is better than
if you're a biden guy going back to the
machine with biden
but again if you're going back to the
machine well the whole base is telling
you that the machine is evil that
america was founded on racism in the
1619
project and all of these really really
bad ideas so it's it's really hard
it's hard to picture someone when i talk
about that that group in the middle that
hasn't made up their mind yet that most
likely decides this election right the
trump people are the trump people
and the die-hard democrats i guess are
the die-hard
democrats that's just harder to define
right now what that is
but that that group in the middle i'm
just and maybe i'm wrong on this
but i'm finding it very hard to figure
out a way that they are going to
break towards biden but anyway let's
let's get this back to the to the debate
tonight low expectations for buying high
expectations
for trump uh we know that what what will
go
viral like what are the stuff that uh
when they say winners and losers it's
like who got more laughs who seemed more
human
who was happier who connected with the
people um but i think
you know what we should all remember is
that you know what debates
do basically are just help craft the
narrative
right so it's like you know somebody
wins one and then they'll say well he
won the last one
now if he wins the second one he's
really set him up himself up to win the
third one but if he wins one
loses the second now it's anybody's
choice in the third but the real
question is does that change any votes
of course what the other question is is
do the votes even matter
because there was another story that
broke over the weekend
uh by project veritas and and you could
say that you don't like project veritas
or some of that you don't like some of
the things
they've done they actually have a pretty
decent track record and in a world where
the media is completely collapsing i
think they probably proudly put their
track record of exposing things up to
against any mainstream outlet but
they've got this ballot harvesting video
that's
uh that's spreading like wildfire it's
got over a million views already
um and it comes out of ilhan omar's
district in minnesota
where they're basically just taking
ballots and dumping them in the garbage
there's a video of it and people talking
about it so you should check out the
project veritas video
um so again that goes to like what you
know it's all it's a lot of theater like
this is all theater it's sort of like
the show must go on
right and we can enjoy the show or you
can hate the show or you could
be part of the show or not be part of
the show but at the end of the day
uh this is about what people do on
election day
um i mean
oh you know what let me let me stop for
a second and shift back to
the trump and the tax thing because i
mentioned i would talk about that for a
sec
uh because it's obviously going to come
up tonight it's not one of the things
you know chris wallace
who's the uh the moderator tonight i
guess they release
the the six or so topics that they're
going to discuss and that was before
this trump tax story that came out in
the new york times now first off
the new york times is not a newspaper
let's be very clear about that the new
york times is basically just a
propaganda outlet associated with the
dnc it's not a newspaper anymore it's
just not
um so the fact that they released this
48 hours before the debate
um it's very look trump already said
four years ago in the debates when
hillary was going on
after him about taxes and she said
you're not paying your fair share and
blah blah blah and he's like that's
that makes me smart i think that's the
exact quote that he said and the point
was not that he's doing anything illegal
but you use every loophole you can
everyone does this every every media
elite person right now that's saying
trump doesn't pay his fair share
every single one of these people and i'm
guessing you person watching this right
now when you go to your accountant
right before tax day and you sit down
with them what do you do you go well
what can i write off what can we do
so that my tax bill is less because
nobody
even even the bananas lefty big
government progressives nobody
wants to pay taxes they seem to think
that other people should pay a lot of
taxes apparently
something like that um but what i always
do i go to my accountant
and i say what can we do i want to
obviously it's got to be the buy the
book it's got to be legal i don't want
to do anything illegal but i want to pay
the least amount of taxes i can
i live here in california i'm paying
gavin newsom an awful lot of money
i don't like that so i would like to do
it but i don't do it illegally the point
is if trump had been doing
illegal maneuvers all these years the
irs obviously would have got him at this
point the feds obviously would have got
him at this point
so they break this story
as if it's a story but literally nobody
cares if anything
you get the you get the real libertarian
conservative base
to be more proud of him like oh he did
everything he could not to pay taxes we
don't like taxes we like small
governments so now the base is into it
and then the rest of the media elite
just look like a bunch of hypocrites
because you know they're doing all the
tricks they can all day long
uh to not pay taxes so i think the tax
thing is just
it's just a silly thing if if you want
to have a conversation
about um whether our tax system is
screwed up
uh well then i'll gladly have that
conversation and by the way
in don't burn this book which is
available on amazon and i don't break
this
don't burn this book.com uh i uh lay out
my
uh prescription for taxes and i
basically i'm i'm for a flat tax
with a couple i even throw the conser
the the progressives
a little something meaning that if
you're under 50 grand a year you don't
pay any tax
and if you're over 5 million you can pay
a little bit more as i say in the book
i'm not even sure that's economically
sensible
um but i think you can do that to
to actually show that we can try to get
to something that we can all agree on so
you help the poorest people
and then the people that are the richest
can pay a little bit more i'm not even
sure it even makes any sense but
everyone else
pays 18 simple as that that's what a
sensible plan would be but that's a
separate issue then the people cheating
on their taxes
anyway it's going to be completely
bananas tonight
um i think i'll just make one really
bold prediction
i think it's very possible that if if
biden has a complete
meltdown on stage tonight like if he
really
you know if they don't let him up there
with an earpiece and he really loses it
which is
very possible it just is possible it
just is
um i think he could be out of this race
within like three days i know that
sounds nuts
um but i really do think it's possible
um
i should tell you guys that we will be
live
right here on the youtube immediately
after the debate that's right we're
doing a double
day of live youtube streams so the
second the debate is over i'm
actually told it'll be live a minute
before the debate is over
uh we will be live right here so what
you can do if you want to make sure you
actually see that
is you can subscribe to our youtube
channel and click that notification bell
you got to click it probably 10 times
because they unsubscribe people and that
whole youtube game which
everybody knows about uh the reuben
report team will be eating pizza
we will be eating popcorn drinking wine
and beer
i'm curious to know what you guys will
be eating and drinking during
the festivities so you can let us know
at reubenreport.com and it's it's really
look it's going to be interesting people
and we've got a crazy
crazy six weeks five weeks roughly ahead
of us right now it's like we've got
riots
we've got a pandemic uh we've got an
election
we've got a supreme court situation god
only knows what other surprises are
coming
down the way as i just said i think if
al if biden falters terribly tonight
which could happen like if he just
just has that that mental collapse it's
like they could replace him
you know biden biden got coveted we're
gonna have to replace him like i think
anything can happen again that's not me
throwing out conspiracy theories
i think just we live in a world where
everything is upside down you could wake
up on any given day and there's almost
no headline that you'd be like oh no
that's impossible
like pretty much everything seems
possible right and that that's just the
world as it is and i hope
what i'm trying to do here is working
which is making you not feel that crazy
about it so we will be live
uh michael what time is that that'll be
about
8 30 that's 8 30 pacific
i guess that's 11 30 eastern so we'll be
live and i'll have a few drinks in me so
we'll see what you guys can get out of
me
i thank you for watching and enjoy the
debates
and go america
you